joe biden has made a major
selection to his cabinet pick for his
incoming cabinet
that i wholeheartedly absolutely
think is a disastrous choice and uh that
is the choice of nira tandon
to lead omb omb is the office of
management and budget that's a cabinet
level position
i believe this is by far joe biden's
worst selection
i like many of joe biden's picks
alejandro mayorkas for the
department of homeland security
secretary super interesting
a good pick well qualified janet yellen
for treasury we've already talked about
her i think that's a good pick
there's a long list of good selections
by joe biden and all qualified
but nira tandon is a disastrous
selection and is a sign of cow towing to
the worst
of the worst of the establishment
democratic party cronyism
that is off-putting and distasteful and
disgusting
niro tandon is primarily known
as a hillary clinton loyalist to put it
put to put it plainly
uh one of these democratic elites that
helped
sink bernie back in 2016. she's proposed
cutting social security in the past
back in 2010 nira tandon was involved in
a
center for american progress which is
the the organization she ran
a cap proposal to cut social security
but not only do i think this is a bad
pick
because it is exactly the type of
democratic party cronyism
that the party should be getting away
from i also think this is a bad pick
because it's controversial on both sides
with many republicans thinking that niro
tandon is just bonkers
and progressives thinking she's a true
centrist establishment
shill that is the epitome of the problem
of the democratic party so you've got
the bernie left furious because they see
this
as just a smack in the face her
organization
regularly going after bernie as i
already mentioned
but you've also got right wingers who
think niro tandon
is nuts republican senator lindsey
graham calling nera tandon
a quote nut job and i don't really care
what
crazy republicans think about joe
biden's picks
except that they will
have the ability to create real
obstacles for confirmation
and it will be a battle for joe biden to
get
someone confirmed that much of the left
doesn't like either
lindsey graham saying quote if you want
to make sure this nut job tandon
doesn't become the director of the
budget in charge of omb
then make sure we win georgia so
republicans using this
to try to win those races in georgia
they may create obstacles and
it'll be a confirmation battle the
progressive wing of the democratic party
is disgusted and republicans have
already signaled
that they could block confirmation of
neera tandon
the left and right both have problems
this
is definitely not in keeping by the way
with joe biden's unite the country theme
unless he means unite the country
against near a tandem
i see no gain from this politically i
see no
benefit from this for a biden
administration just in terms of the
day-to-day
now much of the case being made for niro
tandon
is an identity case she grew up in
section 8 housing and now she's going to
run the national budget
okay but she could run it in a good way
or a bad way the fact that she grew up
in section 8 housing doesn't tell us
whether she's a good or bad pick
she's the first indian american in this
position
okay but is she the right person for it
and as i've said before
identity can be enlightening and
informative
if the person is otherwise qualified
kamala harris is a
very well qualified person to be vice
president
she could be president on day one if it
were necessary and
it's very interesting and inspiring that
she will be the first female president
or vice president ever in history
that's really interesting that's
inspiring that's relevant
but if she were unqualified being a
woman
wouldn't be a reason to put her in that
position and in seeing many of the
defenses of near attendance so far
i'm seeing experience and connections
mentioned
which means she's an insider okay and
i'm seeing identity stories which by
themselves don't do too much for me
now in the meantime nira tandon has been
on a tweet delete rampage deleting about
1800
tweets many of them critical of bernie
sanders
and of elizabeth warren so to be clear
i can be against this selection and be
in favor of others
yesterday on a live stream i mentioned i
don't at all like this selection of niro
tandon
and i started getting emails and
messages from people saying david why
are you attacking joe biden this is not
the time to attack biden
listen biden won and he's going to be
president if saying
i think nera tandon is a bad pick
while lots of other picks are good and
if that counts as attacking joe biden
we're gonna have a long four years ahead
of us my friends but i think most of the
audience understands
um i can dislike this selection and like
others and still believe that voting for
joe biden over donald trump was the
right choice
as i did and as i continue to believe
let me know your thoughts what am i
missing
am i misguided in my criticism of near a
tandem let me know i'm on twitter
at deepakman what if you could read 10
books
in just one sitting that's exactly what
one of my favorite apps lets you do it's
called blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for if
there's a full book you're thinking
about buying
you can use blinkist to get a sample
first just think
how much you can enrich yourself by
being able to soak up an
entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes
i recently checked out the book podcast
marketing strategy by daniel rolls
and kieran rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to what i'm
doing
really recommend it blinkist has books
on politics philosophy science they have
27 different non-fiction categories and
a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video